foreign
ago when Elon Musk took over Twitter and
began making sweeping layoffs he was
condemned as a heartless profiteer a man
who took over a company and gutted it
out of spite or just for fun but recent
events would suggest that musk was was
only ripping the Band-Aid off he was
doing what needed to be done but doing
it in much in a much you know quicker
fashion a few months after those layoffs
the rest of big Tech is now involved in
its own Purge of its Workforce the daily
wire reported this week quote Spotify
revealed plans to cut head counts by six
percent due to macroeconomic turmoil
following similar moves from other
prominent technology firms Spotify CEO
Daniel eek or Eck informed staff members
in a mundane note that the music and
audio platform would reduce head count
to streamline operations the
announcement implies that 600 of the
company's 9 800 employees will lose
their position Spotify is one of the
several technology companies to announce
layoffs in recent weeks as a response to
overzealous hiring in the sector and
broader economic woes Microsoft revealed
that the company would dismiss some 10
000 employees while Google would reduce
its head count by approximately 12 000
positions and Amazon plans to dismiss 18
000 employees more than 46 000 workers
have been discharged from prominent
American technology companies in the
first month of 2023 according to a
report from crunchbase even after firms
in the sector dismissed 107 000
positions last year
so perhaps it turns out the most
successful businessman in the world made
those layoffs because it was the right
business decision maybe he didn't become
the richest human in history by doing
things haphazically or without good
reason
there's an interesting thought what's
even more interesting is that big Tech
employees themselves while still
complaining about layoffs have in the
past inadvertently revealed why the
layoffs were necessary
case in point Nicole Sai who's a partner
Services program manager at Google or I
should say a former partner Services
program manager at Google Psy like
several Infamous examples from the
Twitter ranks enjoyed posting these
insufferable Day in the Life videos to
tick tock where she documented her
exploits throughout the day which mostly
consisted of bragging about all the
perks that she enjoyed as a big Tech
minion I still remain you know
personally perplexed as to why or how
these Day in the Life videos become so
popular I can understand watching such a
video about somebody who lives an
interesting life
and does interesting things like maybe a
day in the life of a scuba diver who
explores shipwrecks or of a scientist on
a remote research station and are in
Antarctica or even one of those guys who
repairs power lines 150 feet up like I'd
watch that that day in the life of that
guy I want to see
these are impressive jobs that would
make for fascinating content
a day in the life of a Silicon Valley
pencil Pusher doesn't exactly
measure up
yet even so Nicole Sai posted this here
it is
a day in my life working from the Google
LA office I always grab some candy from
the reception before heading in this
used to be an old aircraft hanger so the
decorations hanging from the ceiling
kind of looks like an aircraft flying in
before it was a Google office this
aircraft Hangar belonged to Howard
Hughes so there's tons of memorabilia
next I'm gonna pass by these art
installations they're a really good
photo op or you can sit in there and get
some work done I'm gonna head to the
coffee shop to grab some coffee and a
fruit cup since I missed breakfast and
then I'm heading over to this butterfly
themed room to take my first meeting and
I'm gonna head over to the confetti room
to take my next meeting it's so sparkly
and beautiful in here I love that a lot
of our rooms are themed then I'm gonna
grab my two favorite drinks which is
this green tea and coconut water next
I'm gonna go upstairs and grab some
lunch they always have pizza in a
variety of different vegetables and meat
the food is always really good and of
course everything you see in the office
is free on my way out of the cafe I ran
into a doogler which is a dog googler
and ran into some ghosts when they were
renovating the office there were a lot
of spooky stories from the crew so
there's a whole area in the office where
you can listen to them then I got more
work done and headed over to the massage
chairs to wrap up my day let me know
what you want to see next
[Music]
well it's important to get that massage
in after a grueling day of eating candy
drinking coconut water taking selfies
perusing art installations
petting the dog googler
Not In fairness she did take two
meetings Okay so there weren't too many
that and and that was her entire day she
had the two meetings and the rest of
that mostly just hobnobbing around
taking it easy
attending a meeting or two
the one thing missing from her day or uh
from uh from her day is is work
or anything that we might call work
she didn't like do anything or create
anything or make any important decisions
from the looks of it
it's not clear from that video why
Google needs her in the building and it
apparently wasn't clear to Google either
which led to this unintentionally
hilarious follow-up video here it is a
day in my life getting laid off at
Google so I woke up to this really
ominous text from my boss and I honestly
had no idea what it was going to be
about so I called her the minute I woke
up and saw this and she told me to check
the news and my email so I rushed
downstairs to find out that I had lost
access to basically everything I
couldn't log into my email or even check
my calendar I called my boss back and we
just sobbed over the phone because she
was also finding out about my layoff for
the first time today too I started
getting calls from a bunch of my
co-workers and started finding out who
else was let go on my team and some
neighboring teams as well but I think
the worst part is that it seems like no
one was consulted on this decision and
everyone was just finding out about the
layoffs at the same time it just felt
like a really bad game of Russian
Roulette and there was no consistency
around who was let go it was also not
Performance Based so it just felt really
random I opened up LinkedIn which
honestly was not great for my mental
health there were so many people who
were in the same boat that were both
equally as shocked and blindsided but it
did help me feel a little less alone
honestly I spent so much of the day
crying that I just felt so tired from
being sad and wanted to do something
that would just make me feel better
luckily I have an annual pass so I
headed over to Disneyland because I
wanted to go eat my feelings so I
started off with a cinnamon Galaxy
churro and then went to the Teriyaki
Turkey Leg this is a special limited
edition item for the Lunar New Year
celebration at Disney California
Adventure I had some rice krispie a corn
dog did some drawing and even had
another churro I don't really know
what's next for me but I'll be vlogging
my journey and posting more content
about it so feel free to follow along
I you know I have a sick sense of humor
so I I really want someone with an even
sicker sense of humor to make a a video
parody video of like
what would happen if one of these people
was on like death row
and had to do a day in the life of their
execution
I just think that'd be fun
here's a day in the life when I'm being
executed I Woke up had my last meal
a couple things first of all she says
that the layoffs were a really bad game
of Russian Roulette which seems to
suggest that there's such a thing as a
good game of Russian Roulette the whole
point of Russian Roulette is that
someone dies at the end so it's going to
be a very bad day for someone at least
although maybe not for you so okay
second she she just got laid off lost
her source of income and her first
reaction was to run down to was it
Disneyland to blow her discretionary
funds on carnival snacks
doesn't seem like a great strategy
third listen I don't have anything
against this woman I'm um
predisposed to dislike her because she
works for big Tech but uh for all I know
she's a very nice and delightful person
it's probably not but my ability to feel
sympathy for your tears is severely
limited when you take out your phone to
capture your tears on video
I have been sad in my life I've
experienced setbacks like we all I've
never once felt the urge in the midst of
that sadness to document it with my
phone that's actually the last thing I
would I would want is I'm very sad about
something and then I have a phone in my
face
it's the last thing I want the instinct
to pull out your phone while you're
crying is not one that I can begin to
understand and it automatically makes
your sadness at least partially
performative
because you're using it for Content
you're using it for clout
you're not taking your own Misfortune
seriously and so why should I take it
seriously
finally there's a lesson here that I
hope Nicole learns and all younger
people learn
um it's not
fun but it's it's the truth
in the Working World
everyone is expendable
everyone is replaceable
now you're not Expendable as a human
being I'm not saying that you as a human
are expendable you're not Expendable in
certain contexts like in the context of
your family you're not an Expendable
person but at your job you can be
replaced and eventually one way or
another you will be
whether you quit fired laid off retire I
mean one way or another eventually
you're replaced
and that's the case for all of us
but you can greatly mitigate your
replaceableness uh you can you can make
yourself much less Expendable you can
make it so that though you can still be
replaced there are not that many people
who can replace you
your own vulnerability in this regard
the reality that you will never be
entirely indispensable that shouldn't be
a cause for despair but rather it should
drive you and make you more ambitious
and Innovative and Propel you to work
harder
not a paranoid way but just in a like
staying humble and working hard kind of
way
and if it does if it does motivate you
that way then then even if and when you
are replaced
you're nearly certain to continue on the
path to success though by the way of a
detour
we will always be to one degree or
another Expendable at our jobs but you
can become virtually undeniable in
pursuit of your larger goals if you hone
your abilities if you never become
entirely complacent if you work harder
than everybody around you you will be
successful it is virtually guaranteed I
have never known in my life a
hard-working talented person who was not
by some measure successful
maybe not rich but rich is not rich is
is one potential manifestation of some
forms of success it is not in and of
itself success so maybe I'm not saying
that every hard-working talented person
is is a millionaire
but they are all set successful at the
same time
so here's your problem Nicole and it's a
problem shared by many
you don't seem to be doing anything or
even attempting to do anything that
cannot be done by virtually anyone
that that is the most vulnerable
position you can put yourself in
when you are contributing in a way that
could just as well be emulated by nearly
anyone who walks in the door
in fact your contributions can be
absorbed by other people without
anything really being lost
you've made yourself highly highly
replaceable
and you've deprived yourself of any
Leverage
further down the professional ladder
there are some workers in the fast food
industry who find themselves in the same
position they clamor for higher wages
but they have almost no leverage because
their positions can be simply erased and
replaced by touch screens
now the best response then is to work
hard develop your skills become
Innovative put yourself in a position
either in the same industry or somewhere
else where you you you bring something
to the table
that very few people can match now this
isn't about defending corporations or
greedy billionaires I'm not telling you
how I wish things were
this is not my vision of how I want the
world to be
I'm telling you how it is
and all we can do is to start with
confront the fundamental reality for
what it is and figure out how to succeed
within its confines
whether you like the confines of reality
or not
there they are
you have to figure out how to operate in
spite of them That's the Way Forward
though for now I must say you are still
canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
shows and move over to members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]